ten Cocoa Beach City manager Jim
McKnight is with me now good morning
thanks so much for being here I know
it's a busy time for you so the concern
is a storm surge of about seven feet
here what are you telling to residents
well the first thing is for people to
stay off the beach obviously we have a
pretty robust dune system we think that
will hold what we need to have held but
certainly we're gonna have some surge
and potentially some loss of beach the
other concern of course the wind I know
you have mandatory evacuation here in
this community how many people have
evacuated well we don't know the actual
number but we know we still have a
number of residents or that are still
here but we do have our visitors and
tourists are off the barrier island yeah
because this is a big tourist
destination most people get on cruise
ships from here absolutely they're all
gone they're gone
I know you mentioned though you do have
a hundred-year-old resident who says
she's not going she wants to stay what
do you do we just check on her regularly
and the police force knows that and
that's that's their job to make sure
she's okay
even in just the time you've been here I
can feel the wind really picking up at
what miles per hour do you get concerned
about the safety of your residents and
say absolutely don't even go outside
your home well generally when it hits 50
miles per hour we're going to see
responding to emergency calls you're
gonna stop
we will stop we will not put our
employees in danger so 50 is generally
about when we stop responses so they
need to stay inside their structures
don't wander around stay home alright
you must be breathing some reading
somewhat of a sigh of relief this
morning is it looks like the latest
track has this storm moving east and up
the coast yes we are pleased to see that
and we believe that while that is the
case we know a jock here or jog there
and we're still dealing with hurricane
force but we're cautiously optimistic at
this point in time all right Jim
McKnight thank you so much for joining
us we appreciate it all right let's go
back to Anthony in New York Anthony
thanks Nora